Python also has a useful way to assign multiple variables at once.
These three assignments can be abbreviated using
multiple assignments like this: x is still assigned to two,
y to three, and z to five.
You can use this when you're assigning closely related variables like
the width and height of an object or an object coordinates.
In this example, we used x,
y, and z as variable names.
However, normally, we'd want something more descriptive.
x, y, and z would be
appropriate variable names for something like coordinates in a 3D space.
But for most other situations, we can do better.
For example, if you were computing the population density of
Mountain View by dividing the population by the land area,
this is one way to compute the correct answer.
But it's much clear with these variable names,
which are actually descriptive of the values they represent.
In addition to being descriptive,
there are a few things to watch out for when naming variables in Python.
First, only use ordinary letters,
numbers, or underscores in your variable names.
They can't have spaces and need to start with a letter or underscore.
Second, you can't use reserved words or
built-in identifiers that have important purposes in Python,
which you'll learn about throughout this course.
There are also links below. Using them as variable names will lead to
errors or problematic situations when you try to use that word for its intended purpose.
Third, the pythonic way to name variables is to
use all lowercase letters and underscores to separate words.